en fait les journalistes
sortent ça en gros tige genre non je ne
regrette rien je veux être respecté
enfin je veux dire c'est ridicule tu
fais une interview et alors ça devient
un truc bateau on dirait que j'ai fait
du porno ce qui est ce qui est faux
et alors c'était quoi ces questions
méchantes que tu avais préparé pour moi
j'ai pas préparé de question pour toi et
je veux pas être méchant avec toi tout
le monde t'a dit de pas être méchant
avec moi
je sais pas moi des trucs comme on dit
dans les émissions de télé
qu'est-ce que je fais les artistes
viennent à la télévision
en trois
phrases en Italie j'ai appris l'italien
j'ai travaillé avec des gens super et
avec Anthony Quino et ça va sortir au
Festival de Venise tout ça là je vais
faire un film avec José Giovanni année
et tirer de son bouquin
mon ami le traître que c'est un titre
génial je pense que tu en penses
que j'ai en projet et ben dans le style
viennois puisqu'on continue je veux dire
que lorsqu'il est venu avec la
métamorphose de Kafka et bien moi je
vais interpréter la traductrice de Kafka
Milena jasenska avec Véra Belmont donc
qui est productrice et réalisé
non c'est vrai ah tu es un peu dis donc
moi je t'ai connu tu étais gamine là tu
fais petite bonne femme
pour méditer ce que je voulais faire et
j'ai pas tourné pendant deux ans donc
j'ai eu le temps de réfléchir et je me
suis dit que j'avais envie de faire des
choses que j'aimais et de laisser
derrière moi
ça tourne une page
faites comme ça à la va-vite
[Musique]
et donc l'histoire la vie de millénaire
jasenska c'est génial je sais pas qui va
encore interpréter Kafka mais je pense
que
[Musique]
je sais pas pourquoi pas en tout cas
j'ai envie de voir la pièce parce que la
métamorphose pour l'interpréter je crois
que déjà pour le visualiser c'est assez
difficile même en ligne pour le faire en
pièce ça doit être
et son accent est utile parce qu'il a
vraiment un accent de
cafards
alors dis donc j'ai lu dans le journal
dans quel journal
j'ai lu dans le journal que tu voulais
plus te mettre toute nue
c'est vrai toute façon j'ai jamais aimé
ça je crois que toutes les actrices
souffrent un peu de
des répercussions de la révolution
sexuelle tu vois je dirais eu un
engrenage comme ça on a été jusqu'à
l'extrême
se mettent à poil dans les journaux quoi
que c'est un peu ridicule finalement non
pas dans les journaux dans les films non
mais je trouve que bon une scène
sensuelle par-ci par là je dis mais il y
a on a été vraiment trop loin quand même
je veux dire 5 par fille jusqu'au bout
je crois que le summum ça a été le film
de belle ok quand même le diable au
corps je veux dire
on peut pas les gens ont envie de rêver
aussi je crois que les actrices elles
sont pas là pour se prostituer
on a envie d'être respecté
on en fait tout un plat et tu sais
comment sont les journalistes tu leur
dis un truc tu leur truc comme ça tu
leur dis tout simplement non
mais tu leur dis tout simplement j'en ai
marre on est exploité c'est vrai je veux
dire pourquoi est-ce que dans la fin
public qui a pas eu seulement une scène
de danse pourquoi il y en a eu trois et
pourquoi il a pris il y a eu 5 scènes de
nuls tu vois je suis en chacune moi j'en
aurai beaucoup moins souffert quoi et en
fait les journalistes sortent ça en gros
tige genre non je ne regrette rien je
veux être respecté enfin je veux dire
c'est ridicule tu fais une interview et
alors ça devient un truc bateau on
dirait que j'ai fait du porno ce qui est
ce qui est faux je veux dire parce que
quand même je vous laisse Kiss c'est un
film très intéressant et plutôt intello
et pas grand public je veux dire l'année
des méduses non plus pas vraiment mais
ce que je veux dire tout simplement
c'est que j'ai eu un
je crois qu'on va assumer et que
[Musique]
moi j'ai eu un ras-le-bol quoi je veux
dire déjà c'est devenu difficile je
crois qu'il faut se mettre dans la peau
des actrices comment tu veux
[Musique]
de l'amour du cinéma ce sont lesquels
voilà celle des années 50 je veux dire
celle qui était tout en glamour en
sensualité qui jouait avec leurs
vêtements avec leurs décolleté avec
leurs gants sans citer des noms je veux
dire et pas celle qui se déshabille quoi
je veux dire parce que c'est on fait pas
fantasme fait fantasme personne
être actrice c'est faire de la promo
pour des films ce qui est chiant
c'est-à-dire toi là c'est bien parce que
tu fais pas de promo mais je veux dire
les acteurs ils viennent à la télé pour
faire la promo ensuite faut se mettre
toute nue dans les films parce que les
gens ils veulent qu'on se met toutes
nues ensuite les gens c'est terrible les
gens s'intéressent à ta vie privée les
journalistes s'intéressent à donner
assez bien de défendre quand même tu
donnes ce que tu veux donner donc tu
sois poursuiviaux
avec les fiancés c'était
comment dire à cette étoile qui était
d'accord quoi non j'étais pas d'accord
mais les fiancés les pauvres je dirais
non mais être suivi par les paparazz
jusqu'au Bahamas alors que tu te crois
seul au monde avec ton fiancé
quelle conclusion tu tires surtout tes
sur tes histoires là qu'on a lu dans la
presse
quelle histoire
ensemble et clic-clac
alors j'ai vu j'ai vu comment il
s'appelle l'autre jour Anthony Delon
dans une émission de télévision et il
disait qu'il voulait plus parler de toi
c'est dur la vie là quand même pourquoi
j'ai pas vu
on demande avec qui
est ta fiancée elle s'appelle Béatrice
maintenant je pense qu'à mon âge si tu
veux c'est la seule chose qui reste à
faire je te le dis à pas ça par contre
demain
[Musique]
35 ans
39 ans
à 30 ans tu faisais déjà 39 ans
j'ai l'impression que je vais de plus en
plus jeune
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu